the new york times's mara gay went on
television yesterday
to push her usual race hustling nonsense
no surprise there nothing newsworthy
but during the interview she exposed an
awkward fact about herself and her
radical colleagues
she admitted that she is disturbed
by the american flag i think as long as
they see americanness as the same as one
with whiteness this is going to continue
we have to figure out
how to get every american a place at the
table in this democracy
but how to separate american-ness
america from whiteness until we can
confront
that and talk about that this is really
going to continue i was on long island
this weekend
uh visiting a really dear friend and i
was really disturbed i saw
you know dozens and dozens of pickup
trucks with
uh you know uh explicatives against joe
biden
on the back of them uh trump flags
and some cases just dozens of american
flags
which you know uh is also just
disturbing because essentially the
message was clear it was
this is my country this is not your
country
i own this explicatives
wow new york times editorial board make
maybe that's why she's on the board
she's making up
new words wants to separate
american-ness
from whiteness got to get the white
people out of there not just disturbed
by white people though
disturbed by the american flag
the symbol of the country itself what
we've been saying
you know i hate to say i told you so
what we've been saying from the
beginning
this is not a movement against even some
part of the country or some group in the
country it's a movement
against the country itself now mara's
defenders are saying
she was taken out of context in reality
of course the problem is that she was
being taken entirely in context
lots of other leftists getting caught
saying ugly things in context
too that yale lecturer who wants to
shoot white people joe biden's
degenerate son hunter
and even the vice president of the
united states we will give context
to the context of michael knowles is the
michael knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from felicia who says
i like to tune in to see what crazy
claims
michael will make that will come true
later on thank you i'm so pleased to
hear that
this has been a little strange recently
the things that we were saying on the
show
over a year ago that everyone including
many conservatives
said was completely insane that's all
being proven 100 completely correct
this actually the same sort of thing is
happening to alex jones at the moment
little in in different ways but i am
reminded once a
professor of mine from college who
spends much of her time on the internet
uh trying to get attention by mentioning
her students who are now in public
life she does this to ben's ass too she
once referred to me as the alex jones of
the bougie
so may i think that's what that
commenter is seeing as well you know
when people had to get you
very important to protect your your
information your daddy your
correspondence
that's why you gotta check out start
mail free email services
are not really free okay you don't get
something for nothing
folks not on this earth you pay with
your privacy
since those companies have access to
every email you said and received big
tech can sell your data to the highest
bidder which is why i trust start mail
to secure my email start mail keeps my
email private
period every email is encrypted even if
the recipient does not use
encryption which means big tech cannot
read scan
analyze or sell one's personal
information
ever start mail also prevents government
agencies from spying on you
like in dragnet operations with start
mail deleted
means deleted gone forever start mail
uses their own servers it means they
can't be put out of business
you get unlimited anonymous aliases this
feature protects your main email address
from spam and phishing attacks
guys it's 20 21 you've seen what's going
on
even just this past week you've seen
what's going on with email security
don't trust big tech you shouldn't start
securing your email privacy with start
mail sign up today you'll get 50
off your first year go to start mail.com
knowles that is start mail with the t
s t a r t mail.com knowles for fifty
percent off your first year start
mail.com slash
knowles mara gay was was driving around
and she was horrified because she saw
american flags this is this is very very
terrible
the american flags are the if a white
person waves the american flag this is
proof that america has something to do
with whiteness
and that's horrible and people don't
have a seat at the table
notice what she's saying here she's not
just saying
that america needs to no longer be
synonymous
with whiteness right she's not just
saying that other people have
something you know other types of people
brown people black people
have something to do with america too
she's saying that america needs to be
separated completely separated from
whiteness that when white people and
conservatives
or you know those are not the same group
but she's lumping them in together
when they are waving the american flag
when trump supporters are waving the
american flag
that that is terrible that's very
disturbing the irony of course too is
that donald trump did better among
non-white groups than virtually any
republican in recent memory actually the
only group that he didn't gain
uh in in votes during the 2020 election
was white people but
again the facts don't really matter to
maura gay mara gay doesn't even
know how to pronounce basic words right
she's referring to explicatives
so this is a radical claim to say that
we've got to totally separate america
from whiteness because
america's brought in lots of other
people and plenty of people of all
different backgrounds have contributed
to america
however if you get rid of the white
people
you get rid of a lot of america don't
you the pilgrims on the mayflower gone
the settlers at jamestown gone the
founding fathers
gone you abraham lincoln gone you look
what
i mean even today what i mean white
people are 60 of the country so if you
completely separate
white white people from america what do
you what do you have
you have a rather different looking
country
very different thing than saying let's
bring some other people into the country
let's acknowledge the contributions of
other people that's not what this woman
is saying and she proves it with that
final comment i'm disturbed by the
american flag she says
so the new york times comes out and
defends this woman she they say new york
times editorial board member mara gay
his comments on msnbc have been
irresponsibly taken out of context
her argument was that trump and many of
his supporters have politicized
the american flag the attacks on her
today are ill-informed and grounded in
bad faith
oh my goodness oh my goodness i have a
feeling marigay just wrote this from the
new york times communications
department just since
the new york times doesn't know basic
words since the new york times doesn't
understand very basic facts of language
i should teach them about this word
politicize you can't politicize
a flag a flag is by definition
political a nation's flag refers to its
politics it refers to the public
the flag is is a political symbol
what they're taking issue with here is
that the flag used to be a political
symbol that was embraced by all
americans no matter their
partisan differences but today it has
become a political partisan symbol
of the right because the left hates the
flag because the left
hates the country because the left
protests the flag
says that the flag is as a symbol is a
symbol of
awful terrible bigoted racist whatever
because they hate the symbol and they
hate the symbolized this is why they
protested on football fields this is why
they protested on sneakers this is why
they protested in the halls of congress
and this is why they're embracing now
other flags like the rainbow flag
there's some new rainbow flag they're
embracing that one like the blm flag but
not the american flag if anyone has
politicized the american flag
it is the left but what is the context
here what is the context that is missing
i don't i don't really understand what
that
could be she's very clear now
it's worth pointing out that maura gay
is not the brightest bulb in the pack
okay marigay very famously went on msnbc
with brian williams and uh detailed how
forever
all of the money that mike bloomberg had
spent on his political ads
he could have given americans each one
million dollars
you see it as a possibility if he wants
to spend a billion bucks
beating this guy he could do it
absolutely
um somebody tweeted recently that um
actually with the money he spent he
could have given every american
a million dollars got it let's put it up
on the screen it when
i read it uh tonight on social media
it kind of all became clear bloomberg
spent 500 million on ads
u.s population 327 million uh don't tell
us if you're ahead of us on the math he
could have given each american one
million dollars and have had lunch money
left over
it's an incredible way of putting it
it's an incredible way
of putting it it's true it's disturbing
it does
it does suggest you know what we're
talking about here which is
there's too much money in politics you
just keep
waiting for one of these two geniuses to
realize
that they're off by oh what five orders
of magnitude
six how many for the amount of money
mike bloomberg could have paid
every american one dollar
a little more than one dollar not one
million dollars one dollar but
this woman is not intelligent and she's
not educated and
the same obviously is true of brian
williams
this is not context it's this is a
classic leftist gaffe
where you accidentally say what you
really mean she's not the only one
another
anti-white agitator had the exact same
excuse you remember that lady at yale
dr aruna kilani well dr aruna kilanani
who said that she
has fantasies of shooting white people
in the head and dragging their dead
bodies around
and that the world would thank her for
it she's come and said
she was taken out of context she says
quote too much of the discourse on
race's dry
bland regurgitation of new vocabulary
words like
what was that word that margay made
explicative yes
uh with no work in the unconscious no
work in the unconscious
pause right there she's saying too much
of this
is this dry sort of jargony
you know opaque language and that
doesn't have
work in the unconscious what on earth
does that mean that's you're
you're doing what you're accusing others
of doing anyway she says
if you want to hit hit the unconscious
you will have to feel real negative
feelings my speaking metaphorically
about my own anger was a method for
people to reflect on negative feelings
to normalize negative feelings because
if you don't it will turn into a violent
action
that not only is that incoherent it's
actually the opposite of true
she's saying that you need to feel truly
feel hatred for white people
otherwise you might harm white people
you need to you need to feel
hatred for people you need to let that
hatred flow through you
or else you might act on it but that's
not how
psychology works what what happens is
the things you think actually have a
relation
a positive correlation with the things
that you do
this is a very basic observation we even
call it the near occasion of sin
if you're sitting at the bar there's a
cute girl at the end of the bar and you
just think about how great it would be
to pick that girl up and take her home
you will be more likely to do that if
you sit and stew on your anger and you
have that guy at the other end of the
bar you want to punch him in the face
the more you sit and stew and work
yourself up and get your emotions going
the more likely you are to actually
punch that guy in the face
it's this is a completely opposite
understanding of
of a human nature and human psychology
not surprising though because this lady
is a kook
now another yeah nicholas christakis he
was the
the yale professor who was screamed at
by the girl who said that yale is not an
intellectual space
it's supposed to be a place of comfort
in home that was about five or six years
ago
uh christakis he's a kind of soft
liberal
but you know he says many sensible
things but he's still still a liberal
basically
he says the racism expressed by dr aruna
kilanani in the in
grand rounds at yale just released by
barry weiss is deeply worrisome and
counterproductive
of course as an invitee she is free to
speak on campus but her views must be
soundly rejected
nope uh she is free to speak on campus
this is this is tolerated but
christakis's understanding of academic
freedom here is farcical it's a hoax
it is completely playing into the hands
of the left if this woman
said the same thing about black people
she would not be permitted on campus
nor should she be i don't think it's i
don't think our universities should be
open to people talking about shooting
whole groups of people in the head
but we're supposed to say she's free to
speak on campus because it's against
white people it's a double standard
it's it's based on a flawed
understanding of of academic freedom and
if we want to preserve
our liberal education and our free
speech you know what we got to do we
need to censor some things we need to
recognize
that there will be limits always i'm not
even saying there should be i'm just
saying that's the
fact of society some things are in some
things are out this is the topic of my
upcoming book speechless controlling
words controlling minds available now
for pre-order i strongly recommend
you check it out i also recommend you
check out rock auto
you need a car part you have the brick
and mortar store down the street
you have your computer or your phone
right in front of you and you think
you fool you think that you're going to
go to the brick and mortar store you
think that's going to be easier right so
you go there
oh you know what happens they ask you a
bunch of dumb questions about your car
you don't know the answer to they go in
the back
probably to an empty room they don't
have the part they go online probably to
rockauto.com
they order the part they charge you
twice as much oh if only
you had listened to me if all you're
going to be kicking yourself you're
going to say ah
michael was right i could have gone to
rockauto.com a family business
they got the same prices for pros and
do-it-yourselfers they don't
change with all the gimmicky nonsense
every tuesday at three you got to buy
but not at wednesday it's like no
it's all right there catalog's so easy
even i can peruse it go to rockauto.com
right now see all the parts available
for your car
truck right now scanner wles in there
how did you hear about xbox
so that they know that we sent you this
yale professor nicholas christakis
is saying look this this psychologist
who came and said she wants to shoot
white people
on campus her views are terrible they're
racist they should be rejected but her
views
of course must be protected on campus
no no they mustn't they wouldn't be in
the other
direction william f buckley jr talks
actually uses almost this exact example
in god and man at yale the superstitions
of academic freedom
the book that launched the post-war
conservative movement in which he says
yale would never permit
a neo-nazi or a white supremacist to
teach in their sociology department now
they might permit a black supremacist
right they may they might
might permit one of these radicals in
the other direction but they would not
permit it going one way because
there are standards and nobody is
advocating that they
they permit neo-nazis to come on camp i
don't think that's what academic freedom
means but likewise we shouldn't tolerate
this crazy lady
speaking of the political standards here
a world health organization member has
come out to say that
china not only did engage in a massive
cover-up
in its role in covet-19 but it actually
it is continuing
to engage in that cover-up the problem
that we face here
isn't the who it's not even really dr
fauci
the problem is that chinese have engaged
in a massive
cover-up that is going on going until
this until today involving destroying
samples hiding records
placing a universal gag order on chinese
scientists and imprisoning
chinese citizen journalists asking the
most basic questions that's what we need
to
to get around so that's a current member
of the who advisory committee jamie
metzel
china is engaging in a massive cover-up
yes obviously that's true
i'm not even interested in that do you
know what cover-up i'm interested in
you know what cover-up is much more
scandalous the cover-up by the media
the cover-up by the united states
government
the cover-up by the executive agencies
like by the nih by dr fauci
it's not just china that's covering this
up yeah they're hiding their numbers
they hid the virus
they're trying to hide their culpability
so did the mainstream media they carried
water for china the whole time so did dr
fauci
carried water for china caught in in
pretty
serious lies saying that the united
states was not funding
gain of function research the kind of
research that beefs up natural viruses
and makes them deadlier and more
transmissible
then he got caught in that and then when
rand paul caught him in that he said
look
we don't fund this and then rand paul
said you're not funding this doctor
who's working on
gain of function research he said look
okay maybe we're funding him
but he's not working on gain of function
research and then
not not two seconds later in the same
breath he says and if he is it's totally
fine i'm only slightly paraphrasing
he's not doing it but if he is it's
totally fine don't worry about it
i want to talk about that cover-up i
want to talk about
how the the media and the fouchies and
all these people said
no chance was this a human-engineered
virus
this is totally 100 naturally occurring
then we find out oh actually it looks
like it was human engineered
we just found that out no chance did
this come from the wuhan institute of
virology
oh actually yeah no it did it almost
certainly did it didn't come from the
white market it came from the lab
no chance did the united states fund
this lab oh whoops here here's a leak
turns out we funded the lab no it's just
lie after lie after cover-up after
cover-up i expect that
from the chinese communist government
and frankly i expect it from the media
and i expect it
from our public health bureaucracy as
well but that's too bad isn't it
it is more scandalous when our guys do
that than when china does that
the lies are so brazen and it's not just
in china got to give him credit lester
holt at nbc news not the most
conservative guy in the world
but lester holt was interviewing kamala
harris
sitting down about her trip to guatemala
and
he asked her a simple factual question
she lied she contradicted herself
he caught her in it and she had nothing
to say do you have any plans
to visit the border at some point you
know
we are going to the border we've been to
the border so this whole this
whole this whole thing about the border
we've been to the border
we've been to the border you haven't
been to the border i
and i haven't been to europe and i mean
i don't know i don't
understand the point that you're making
i'm not discounting the importance of
the borders well i i mentioned it
because even
i know republicans have certainly come
at you on this but democratic
congressman cuellar
has a border district has said to the
you and the president come you know you
can't
see this listen i care about what's
happening at the border i'm in guatemala
because my focus is dealing with the
root causes of migration
there may be some
who think that that is not important
but it is my firm belief that if we care
about what's happening at the border
we better care about the root causes and
address them and so that's what i'm
doing
what kind of an answer was that that was
a classic homily answer it is amazing
that this woman has gotten into such a
position of power
being so incompetent at the retail side
of politics
don't forget people don't like her she
was
one of if not the first person out in
the 2020 democratic presidential
primaries
she is a brazen liar and she's not even
that good at it
but behind the scenes whether it's
behind the scenes
with willie brown in california or
whether it's behind the scenes
doing whatever else she does find
herself in positions of power
why won't you go to the border we have
been to the border
you haven't been to the border well yeah
but i haven't been to europe either
huh wait what you just
we have so we i can't believe i got to
teach people very basic elements of
language here
i got to teach the new york times that
explicative is not a word i got to teach
kamala harris what the first person
plural pronoun is we i know there's a
lot of confusion about pronouns these
days
we involves you
when you come let's say we you're
implying that you have done something
so you said we have been to the border
and then lester holt says you haven't
been to the border and she's like oh
yeah that's true but what's your point
the point is you just lied you lied
right to my face about something that
is easily checked right you say well i
haven't been to europe either yeah we
don't have hordes of
germans pouring over the border right
now yeah right
we don't have 6 000 italians a day
violating our laws and coming so yeah
that
i guess our our border with italy you
know
that that giant ocean there that's not
the biggest issue
the the issue is what's going on at the
southern border and she doesn't want to
get to it
i do think by the way that that part of
the reason
that joe biden has given kamala this job
of dealing with the border stuff is to
twist the knife
is because i don't think biden and
kamala like each other very much i think
kamala
basically took her first big shot during
the campaign by calling joe biden a
racist
okay and biden picked her because it was
a weak field and he had backed himself
into a corner where he said he was going
to pick a black woman and there just
weren't very many choices so it was
either her or that communist karen bass
so he had to pick her but i don't think
he likes her he's sending her down on
this impossible job and she's failing at
it
now that's not even the most outrageous
thing that kamala said
at the border ben is going to be talking
about outrageous things today on his
show
including how hunter biden said
the n-word the and the the single word
that you're not allowed to say hunter
biden said it and no one is going to
care about it
when it comes to political commentary
from a conservative news source in
america is there any question
that the daily wire has the very best of
it from every single one of my episodes
i hope you've seen them all
well some of them in the early days this
they were some were not so great but
you know in the last few years they've
been right on top to
my co-workers podcasts to our writer's
articles
there's always something worth a read or
a listen but as we grow so does our
content
if you don't keep up you might fall
behind when you subscribe
to the daily wire and download the app
you
will find well over a thousand articles
published every month there's something
like 50 articles a day i think
daily video content lots of shows so
much more
download the daily wire app and stay up
to speed with the freshest
conservative voices around no matter
where you are
we'll be right back with a lot more
kamala harris down in guatemala
lying to lester holt's face about how
she has been to the border when she
actually hasn't
but the craziest thing the most radical
thing she said in guatemala
must be must have been taken out of
context that's that's what they say
whenever the left says something
that reveals their true intentions and
beliefs kamala harris said
that she wants ceos from around the
world
to invest not in america
in guatemala i will also continue to
work with ceos around the world
to encourage investment in guatemala and
mr president i look forward to working
with you on that as i shared with you
in washington dc i recently convened
some of our
biggest ceos who have a profound
interest for many reasons
on supporting the work that happens here
in the work that can happen here in
guatemala
to again uplift folks who
may have been overlooked or neglected
but also uplift
the natural capacity and resources of
this beautiful country
so there are two theories on how to deal
with the illegal immigration problem
and these two theories reflect two
radically different visions of the world
there is the liberal empire theory
okay the liberal empire view
tries to deal with illegal immigration
by getting to the alleged
root causes of illegal immigration
so the liberal empire view of the world
is
in the liberal empire view of america
which is being espoused by kamala harris
and joe biden and others
is not that we need to just arrest
illegals and ship them back across the
border where they came from it's not
that we need to
stop illegal aliens from accessing
government services and
getting along just fine in our country
we need to
create thriving economies and thriving
political systems
in basically every country in latin
america
we need the re the root cause of illegal
immigration
is that el salvador and guatemala and
nicaragua and honduras are not very good
countries
they're not very nice they're not
pleasant so people are fleeing them and
they're they don't they're not fleeing
even political persecution a lot of the
time
so much as they're fleeing the lack of
economic opportunity they're not
stopping in mexico right they're not
stopping in the first country they get
to away from their political system
they're going to america so they can
make money okay fair enough i understand
why they're doing that
the root causes liberal empire view is
we
it is our responsibility to turn
guatemala into a thriving
madisonian democracy that has
a booming economy and lots of industry
and then people won't leave
that's what kamal harris wants to do so
she's inviting ceos to guatemala
then there is the
actual way to stop illegal immigration
the actual way to stop illegal
immigration
you might call this the nationalist view
is to say hey
the u.s government has a responsibility
to u.s citizens
and to u.s workers and we're not going
to tolerate you pouring across our
border and when you do it you know what
we're going to do we're going to ship
you back
and if you somehow get through you're
not going to be able to get a job
and if even if you can work in the black
market in some way you're not going to
be able to access any government
services
life is going to be hard for you here if
the first thing you do is
violate our laws if your very presence
in the country
is a crime we're not going to make it
easy for you
and you're going to go back and by the
way if you
if you do make money here and you try to
send it back home we're going to tax
your remittances and we're ju
and we're going to force employers to
make sure that they're not hiring
illegal aliens we're just going to
actually
we're not going to deal with the root
causes whatever that means we're not
going to create thriving madisonian
democracies in honduras
we're just going to stop you from coming
into the country and boot you out when
we catch you
right that strategy
works you will you will not make
madisonian democracies out of all the
countries of latin america it's just
it's just not
that's not how politics works okay and
we and we also don't have the time or
resources to do that
it's it's hard enough to to keep our own
country on the rails
and we're not doing a great job at that
either we're not going to do it for
every other country
in latin america and on earth much as
the liberal imperialists want to
that this nationalist idea is actually
being advocated now not by the extreme
right-wing fascist trump mitt romney
tweeted this out
he tweeted out exactly what i said i
can't believe i'm saying this i agree
with mitt romney
100 on this issue today i know he
changes his views sometimes but
today he and i agree 100 the way to stop
illegal immigration
is to deport illegal aliens it's to
close down our border it's to
put in measures like e-verify it's to do
things like tax remittances
it's to deal with the issue here in
america because that's what the united
states has a responsibility to do deal
with our own country
and protect our own people how
outrageous
if you are out of work there are a lot
of people out of work
you're out of work right now and you're
somewhere in middle america
and you hear your vice president going
out and
lobbying ceos not on your behalf not on
behalf of her own country but on behalf
of some foreign nation somewhere else in
the world
but that's their view that is their view
of the the relationship of the american
government to the american people
that really it has no special
responsibility that the american
government
is the liberal empire and its citizens
really are just the citizens of the
world
so joe biden sends kamala harris to the
border i assume to make her look bad
biden's got big problems in his own
family though
so ben is going to be talking about this
at length today but this is
the big shocking scandal of hunter biden
this this is probably the least shocking
scandal that hunter biden has ever been
involved in
but this is the one that's getting a lot
of attention now hunter biden
used the n-word
in a private text the n-word now
how did the n-word become the n-word you
know this is a word i truly i cannot say
it you we all know what i'm referring to
so i don't need to say it
but this word is the only unutterable
word
in the english language plenty of words
are discouraged but this one is
unutterable
and that's a fairly new situation i
actually detail
how this happened in my upcoming book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds which is available now for
pre-order the new york times was
printing this word until quite recently
actually
but now it won't print this word it will
only print the n-word
hunter biden while texting with his
white very expensive lawyer
said things like true debt
n word now you know there's the two
kinds of n word
hard r and soft r okay
you know i don't i i can't say it
because if i do
i will be banished to the outer darkness
where there's wailing and gnashing of
teeth so i can't even say it
to de describe it to you but
there's there's one that ends in er and
there's one that ends in a
and ah is a little softer and more
colloquial and people use it
in a more friendly context and then the
er is
decidedly unfriendly hunter used the uh
okay so he was used i'm not defending
anything that hunter biden's ever done
for that matter
but he was just using this in a private
message now this is a this is the
unforgivable sin
that's what they're going to get him on
that's what they're going to get him on
no they they actually he won't he won't
face any consequences for this
even though this is supposedly the worst
thing he's ever done the guy
has used illicit drugs the guy cheated
on multiple wives
and including then shacking up with his
dead brother's widow and then cheating
on her with a stripper
with whom he had a child that he refuses
to acknowledge and that joe biden very
cruelly
refuses to acknowledge joe biden will
not acknowledge one of his
grandchildren good old friendly uncle
joe right oh sweet old grandpa joe biden
just will not acknowledge this girl's
existence
can you imagine you're this little girl
your grandpa's the president of the
united states he refuses to acknowledge
that you're alive
all that no big deal now if you said the
n-word
you would get in trouble your life would
be ruined hunter biden completely
different
i'll show you the double standard kelly
stewart she was somebody on espn
apparently she has been fired uh
she was a betting analyst there she has
been fired because
nine years ago she sent some tweets
using a slur for homosexuals
this is a slur that has been very common
in popular discourse over the years
it has meant many things it means a
bundle of sticks it means a cigarette in
the united kingdom
and she used this just on social media
nine years ago
they asked her for it they're not going
to ask hunter biden
they're not going to act they're they're
going to ask megan kelly
for talking about blackface but they're
not going to axe
joy behar jimmy kimmel jimmy fallon
ralph northam justin trudeau for wearing
blackface
because it has nothing to do it has
nothing to do with the rule
itself it has everything to do with the
imposition
that is the mechanism of political
correctness which
is something i observe and explain in my
upcoming book speech just controlling
women's controlling minds
speaking of allegedly offensive things
more statues are coming down
you remember in charlottesville there
was that awful
attack uh was it four years ago really
what i'm not being facetious here
they're actually white guy drove in and
killed a girl
so there was this bad attack and it was
associated with
a march that was ostensibly to defend
defend historical statues specifically
of confederate monuments
and so these issues now are totally
blended together
the the protest and also because there
were some
savory people at this rally but there
were also some very unsavory people
donald trump got
in trouble for saying they were very
fine people on both sides
and they said you called white
supremacists
very fine people joe biden launched his
presidential campaign on that
you can play the tape donald trump
specifically said i'm not referring to
neo-nazis neo or white supremacists or
whatever i'm not referring to them right
but because of this charlottesville has
is now being treated as as one of the
darkest days in the history of the
united states
notice when we talk about black lives
matter which during those blm riots
many many many more people were killed
than at
charlottesville with bad event right but
blm
no that was mostly peaceful that was a
wonderful protest for justice in
progress
but any other event even if it's much
less deadly even if it's much more
contained
that's much much worse because there
obviously is a double standard here so
what about the issue we're not talking
about the guy who killed that lady he's
gonna rot in prison
we're not talking about the bad people
we're just talking about the historical
question
should we tear down statues well the
answer now i guess is yes
robert e lee came down or is coming down
and stonewall jackson is coming down
this is very dangerous stuff and the
fact that some conservatives still don't
get this
is is is a big problem
because we already know how this ends
right
during the charlottesville event
donald trump came out and he said look
maybe you don't like robert e lee maybe
you don't like stonewall jacks robert e
late by the way was actually
rather an admirable guy fought for a bad
cause but he was an admirable guy
but he said maybe let's say you hate
robert e lee you hate stonewall jackson
you hate all these people
it's not about them today they're
tearing down robert e lee tomorrow
they're going to be tearing down thomas
jefferson
and everyone laughed at trump and then
within a year or two
he was proven 100 correct that's what
they were doing i had to go give a
speech at georgetown or george
washington university
to defend george washington because they
wanted to cancel george washington
at george washington university in
washington dc for goodness sakes
that's what happens when you when you
start to tear down your past
there's no limiting principle you're
gonna you're gonna
they're they're going to be tearing down
statues of blm
within some decades because they're
going to find some problems with blm
finally
they're going to tear down everybody
it's a purely negative
campaign okay and what's the what's the
argument
the argument for tearing down all of
these things is that america is an evil
white supremacist terrible country
in which to quote lebron james black
people can't walk out the door without
being hunted down
that is obviously not true just a little
quick clip there was a video out of
chicago
of a cop car driving through a
neighborhood lots of people around
basically all the people around
were black and you can see on the clip
that a woman is twerking on two women or
twerking
on the hood of the cop car as it's
driving and the cops are saying get off
the car
and all sorts of people and i think
basically i think every single person
maybe including the cops in this video
is black
oh i'm sorry three women are twerking on
the cop car lots of people are touching
it and the cops are doing nothing
they're just driving very slowly and
saying please please come off the car
there there is no police brutality
isolated instances
maybe as a as an epidemic problem it
simply doesn't exist
the police are not are not overly
forceful
if anything the police are
insufficiently forceful because they're
letting these people dance on cop cars
while they're driving around
goodness great and i get why they're
insufficiently forceful because they
know that if they use any force their
lives will be destroyed
the reality of the situation in the
united states is
very very different than the narrative
that we are told by the left
[Music]
the argument that america is oppressive
and evil to people with no forget race
for a second
forget even sex let's talk about sexual
identity
that is also ridiculous burger king just
tweeted out yesterday burger king
burger king tweets out quote they're
referring to their chicken sandwich
the chicken is chicken is their chicken
sandwich
says lgbtq plus rights
they don't says what they're just saying
it's like when kirsten gillibrand was
was filmed during her failed
presidential campaign it was during a
pride event she just goes
gay rights i was like well what about
them what are you saying
they say the same thing they say during
pride month
even on sundays your chicken sandwich
craving can do good
we are making a donation to hrc for
every chicken
sold this is a direct shot at
chick-fil-a and through chick-fil-a this
is a direct shot at christians what
they're saying is
that they're going to donate to one of
the most evil organizations in the
entire country
the human rights campaign the human
rights campaign
is the this preposterously named
organization that existed
to get and founded by some very very
unsavory people who
have done very very creepy things uh
founded to redefine marriage
and they they succeeded at redefining
marriage they're the organization with
the equal sign and
because they succeeded at that but they
wanted to keep their money coming in
they now have moved on to the
transgender issue which is ironic
because it seems to in many ways
undercut the homosexual rights issue
and now they're they want you to trans
your kids right so now
the hrc i mean truly a vile wicked
organization
that should not exist in this country is
getting money from your whopper
on pride month even on sundays haha get
it
chick-fil-a is closed on sundays because
it's a christian company but we're an
anti-christian company
yeah we're so subversive we're so
subversive what are you talking about
that's the dominant culture
right now if you if you went out in the
dominant culture
and you espoused a modern secular
atheist liberal worldview on anything on
life on sex on rights on government
do you think that would get you into
more trouble
than if you were a christian and you
went out and just expressed the
christian view of these things no of
course not
you could lose your job you could lose
your place in society you could lose
your reputation
if you espoused christian orthodoxy in
fact if you
want to maintain those sorts of things
your place in society your reputation
your job
very often you have to to some degree
implicitly or explicitly
go along with leftist orthodoxy
and it's very hard to keep up with that
orthodoxy
there is now a battle brewing on the the
sexual revolutionary left
between the bisexuals
and the pan-sexuals what does it pan say
i'm you know being italian i've often
considered myself a pansexual
you get some nice fatty meats frying up
in there oh man that gets
that gets my motor running baby there
are very few no
that's not what it it's not sexual
attraction
to pans and the delicious foods in them
it is
sexual attraction i guess to just
everything or
the sexual identity involving just
everything it's very vague
and this is is offensive to bisexual
people
who actually believe that there is a
gender dichotomy right there's
men and women and those are the two
things there's not more than two things
so a brilliant sexual philosopher
and girl with green hair and tattoos and
piercings and things
and apparently a paper clip through her
nose
came out and explained this issue guess
what
my patience is run out pansexuality is
not inherently biphobic they are both
valid sexualities both of them and while
yes i have seen pansexual people use
that label for questionable reasons
they pretty quickly get it once you
explain things to them
they do and not only that but do you
know who likes to use specific or micro
labels
neurodivergent people sometimes we just
have to do whatever we can to feel safe
and comfortable
and using a more specific label can be
our outlet for that
if you took all that energy you spend
calling people biphobic and saying
they're performing by erasure and just
educated them there would be less
biphobia
there would be less by erasure because
you've explained it
and people will know the difference i've
had it with you guys jesus
okay i've only got a couple minutes here
and i've got to process that and try to
explain it
she's obviously wrong about everything
here but i think what she's trying to
say is that
the pansexual people and the bisexual
people have totally different views of
the world they're completely
incompatible
and contradictory but actually that's
not a problem because we're going to
tolerate all of these things
and we're going to add another
complication here that neurodivergent
people which is i believe it's a
euphemism for
people with autism i could be wrong but
i it refers to people who have
sort of quirky uh ways of seeing the
world
uh i believe that's what it means so
they
actually prefer the specificity so
that's you got to be tolerant of that
too
and if we just have education then we'll
all understand but the problem is you
can't education is not going to solve
this problem of
of incompatible visions right the the
law of non-contradiction you can't
simultaneously hold views
coherently that contradict one another
so
it doesn't solve the problem but she's
she's very exasperated i mean frankly
there's no difference between what this
girl is doing and what john oliver does
or what jon stewart did right they would
just
they would say some stupid liberal
talking point but then they would just
scream an expletive
they'd say you know we need to radically
redefine marriage
or whatever that babies aren't babies
and it's the current year and then they
would just scream like
f you know come on what the f or
whatever and that was supposed to
substitute for an argument where are
people learning this
they're learning it on nickelodeon
nickelodeon now teaming up with the drag
queen
to teach kids about
all of the pan and the buy and the
divergence and
everything it's pride everybody
every color on the pride flag
is a symbol in the sky
and i'm proud to be me every time that i
see
that
[Music]
is a gift orange means healing and we
have to persist in working to heal
the world and healing ourselves
[Music]
all right pause pause hold i can't you
know the it is the pan i was following
it and the trans and i was sort of
following that
and the buy okay then they added the
divergence thing and i thought okay that
seems unrelated but i'll bring that in
and now they're bringing in
environmentalism and i'm extraordinarily
extraordinarily confused i think maybe
that's the point i think the point might
be to keep us confused you know you look
at these things
in context though and and you start to
get the idea i think the point is to
stop us from thinking
to stop us from questioning to stop us
from debating
and to just go along with it i'm michael
knowles this is the michael she'll see
you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show